how could the universe be expanding and
yet galaxies are swallowing each other
wouldn't the push be a greater force or
it has slowed or has a slowdown these
people are totally getting them yeah
okay so it turns out you week where we
live in an expanding universe yeah and
the farther away you are from a memory
object the more manifest is the
expansion of the universe so if you were
really close the expansion of the
universe is so small as to be swamped by
your mutual gravitational attraction so
we and the Andromeda galaxy
two million light-years away we are
falling towards one another even in the
middle of the expansion of the universe
because we are so close
yeah our speeds and our gravity totally
override how how cool how quickly are we
falling towards each other or slowly
however you want to answer it yeah so
you've you're worried about the future
of Earth
yeah worried like do I have to be
worried about like Thursday are like or
like 2020 yes so does it not climate
change but a falling galaxy that I
should because we will collide anywhere
between six and eight billion years from
now and the Sun will die in five billion
years the Sun is a much bigger issue
yeah yeah our concern for you
but presumably by then be able to be
able to plant it hop find another solar
system so it's still something to think
about I think and the reason why I say
is between that period of time because a
galaxy is not a solid it's not a single
point in space there's a huge extended
object so at what point are we colliding
it's like Polyphonic Spree which is a
very big band trustlink okay so it takes
a long time for galaxies to actually
collide yeah there's so larger they're
huge systems will likely survive that
it'll just be a beautiful train wreck in
the sky stars are very far apart from
one another so our solar system is
likely to stay intact throughout this
entire journey
enjoy the ride all right yeah